[Music]
every morning I drive in through the
gates here at Warner Brothers and I'm
reminded it's the first thing I thought
of the first time I saw these gates
we've been here now we're starting our
third season I think about it every day
the scene in blazing Saddles it took
Blazing Saddles towards the end where
the entire cast runs out through the
gates is such a comedy icon moment for
me
Pirandello ish yes yes you know yeah and
I always go through those gates and I
think about that great scene and you
said that there was someone who wandered
into that scene was to be there yeah we
we were shooting harvey korman and bad
guys escaping from Warner Brothers
escaping from the black sheriff who was
Cleavon little was on a horse yep and
and and he was chasing him so the area
in front of Warner Brothers supposed to
be absolutely clear clean and there was
a guy in a kind of a brindle sweater
walking up and down and and he kept you
know and I said to the 80s chasin chase
him away so they did and then I said
action and everybody flew out of Warner
Brothers onto the street aren't too
bright back Avenue would fly and he just
wanted back in and he wondered you know
and everybody ran past him and he
wondered and I said well get his name
get him to sign something and keep him
in it's funny you know yeah he's in the
more I don't even this guy who just
wandered in is in one of the great
comedy scenes of all time just because
he happened to waltz in and we have the
clip I wanted kidding we have the clip I
want I don't believe you'll see if we
can find this guy let's let's let's say
this let's say this I can't believe it
[Music]
[Applause]
we were just talking we were talking
about Blazing Saddles that movie I
really think in a lot of ways to change
the game that's how it felt to me when I
when I watched at the time everyone
thought it's the funniest movie we've
ever seen when that movie came out with
anything cut from that film I mean it
really took everything to the edge did
you take it you know I was very brave I
had final cut so the studio actually
legally couldn't trim it they couldn't
cut anything but I had filmed something
and when I saw it I got scared I got
really got scared I said I'm gonna take
that little scene out it was the scene
in which Madeline Kahn is in her
dressing room with Cleavon little and
after they each knits and Grubin she she
blows out the candles and she says in
her German accent oh is it true is it
true what they say about you people out
value built is it true is it true ha ha
ha it's all in the dark now ah and he
said and Cleavon says I hate to
disillusion you man but you're sucking
on my arm
I said that's a bit further than I
should go